yeah when you said that if you went to
amsterdam your wife would let you bang a
hooker probably why why is she so like
open-minded like so cool
because she knows that i wouldn't even
want to do it me neither nina she's
gonna allow you because she knows you
wouldn't do it but if i said i really
wanted to she would have been okay with
it i tried to tell her everything even
when i attracted to other women i tried
to tell her that go man like i really
wanted to you know bound her i didn't
say that though but you said it a
different way i said it differently i
said you know she has the organ and i do
too
[Laughter]
does it go the same way does she tell
you he has an organ and i do too his
organ wants to beat my organ up just
teeth
she doesn't say that she she really yes
she loves me you know she loves you so
she won't say that but you love her but
you will say that but but the thing is
like why you gotta [ __ ] me
[Laughter]
why you gotta [ __ ] me right in the face
man yeah all right well the thing is
guys is that uh